and then finally the first time I ever
got interviewed she said Danny don't you
feel you're being stereotyped yeah
you're being typecast you're always
playing the meet you come to welcome
everybody to another episode of pop box
and with Mike Tyson I'm Evan Britton and
I'm Mike Tyson Mike what's up brother I
don't know man
knocking them out the park today yeah we
are who's our guest today now you got a
great guest Danny Trejo Danny Trejo man
I'm a huge fan feet now Conair [ __ ]
machete
it was just till dawn dude come on man
some of my favorite movies oh yeah yeah
actually was as he was a real incident
that happened and this were they made a
movie a little closer to that and then
right now I'm doing getting ready to do
a same one with a Craig moss the
director but it's uh it's gonna be
called social security and it's kind of
like a die hard but in the senior
citizen home we've also got Danny of
standing united thank you for having me
how are you know fantastic it's always
great to have you on the pod brother
thank you brother there's there's a
connection between you two guys
and Danny yours in your sobriety your
journey with that and standing united do
you guys do any collaborations do you
know about standing united there
whatever you don't know we run into each
other you know we're all pretty pretty
busy I just uh we're just at a speaking
engagement about a couple weeks ago yeah
yeah okay awesome
the opioid opioid forum yeah yeah
awesome well you guys are doing great
work with that but Danny I mean you're
you're an L a legend man you're from
here right yeah yeah born and raised
lost I was writing a lot census when
when we're riding streetcars I remember
I actually remember streetcar we used to
like like 9 10 years old we would jump
on them and and then the conductor
wouldn't the next time he stopped he
would get off the chases off we jump off
him and then he had to go back on we
jump back on just right then we had to
go all the way from downtown LA to Long
Beach Wow the trolley
would you say I mean back then was LA
much better on the public transit always
the best we had the best public transit
in the world and it always it always
turned a profit every year yeah but then
when the the big car companies came in
right and started buying up all the
tracks right so they basically turned us
the brew in LA as far as how that's a
nasty maybe what we should do is like
confiscate all their money yeah guys it
out to all the people that are like
walking yeah that's what happened right
the Firestone what do they call your
stone just came in and just took them
all yeah and uh the hilarious part is
that we're building a transit system
right now on the same tracks right that
we had before except for now it's like
eight million miles an inch right oh my
god it's a mess the public transport in
LA yeah if you don't know how to
maneuver in Los Angeles you don't drive
you know you have to maneuver yeah and I
think the smartest thing that ever
happened in Los Angeles was ways you've
also got restaurants yeah yeah we've
shot about we've got we started in fact
started as a joke
was during the movie badass and one of
the directors ash was uh he saw I like
good food you know I like to eat that
but I like good healthy food you know
and and you know it's sexy beautiful
frames it's like free-range chicken you
mean that that chick has never been in a
Cell right so he saw this Danny why
don't you open a restaurant
so joking me and my mom had a running
joke you know trails chuckles yeah so
his trails Broncos yeah and we never she
never got a chance so when a said that
and I said I said trails tacos we did
badass then we did badass too then we
did badass on the Bayou that Glover and
uh he brought me a business plan oh wow
wow you know and me being the brilliant
businessman that I am I gave it to my
secretary marry agent
Gloria here read this you know they read
it and said uh it's a no it's a no no
leave position for you it's the first
time Trinity somebody wants to do
something and they don't want 500 grand
up front yeah you know so yeah I listen
to it so the first one we opened was up
on La Brea
yeah and it turned into a Pink's yeah it
just turned into a UH yeah what do you
call it source attract yes but the
reason well the reason why is because
somebody out here in Laguna Beach or
somewhere they said we're having a bike
run to Trails tacos oh my god so and
then the Orange County bikers heard
about it and said hey we're having a
bike run so who shows up there's about a
hundred guys in spandex he's from Laguna
Beach and a hundred guys in leather
God it was funny all the guys are taking
pictures on Harley's and spandex and
also oh my guys in leather taking
pictures on the ten-speeds and [ __ ] you
know further so it people just became a
tourist attraction yeah and where that
was good so then we opened up the one on
on on Cahuenga and then the one in
Pasadena the one in a little Dina yeah
right right the Pasadena Playhouse oh
sweet
worked out every time there's a play we
get deal we get full hell yeah
so ash and Jeff the the two business
partners they're just they're just great
at location it's also you know they took
what's his name advice location location
location Mel Brooks might never been
never ever come on Mike we get what
about trails Donuts yeah pink building
right on the corner of Santa Monica
Boulevard and Highland yeah and it used
to be a place called donut time and
became real famous in a movie called
tangerine there's a movie that they
filmed completely with a with a iPad or
what I thought really yeah come on movie
and so how so it became really a famous
movie so so people come to take that to
that building now it's pictures of
marius iku and you're invited thank
that's the whole family you better bring
them all down
we got vegan we got vegetarian we got
gluten-free gluten-free with my idea
because i work with them autistic kids
yeah and doctors have said that kids are
gluten-free diet is real good for kids
with autism yeah so so uh that's awesome
so we put it in now we got families with
you know mama says I don't have to cook
three meals yeah you know it's like
everybody can can eat her sir so we have
a lot of families that are like regular
customers it's really good
well Danny I read something a quote you
said going back to sort of the bigger
picture of your story and it was
something to the effect of acting was
the first time you felt the same
adrenaline rush that you felt back in
the day when you were stealing cars and
using yeah and doing robberies yeah yeah
yeah tell us a little bit about many got
from that you know being a part of
robberies to you know being in huge
major Hollywood movies I was uh
you know I didn't uncle turned me onto
grass I was eight years old I mean this
is my idol my you know it's like
basically a lot of problems that young
people have are our role model pickers
are yes and right I mean we don't know
how to pick role models yeah and and and
then in in in a lot of time in
neighborhoods it's a if you role models
are few and far between you can either
be like a construction worker can be a
role model yeah or a cop or you
gangsters
my uncle I'll never forget I will never
forget my uncle Gilbert and a guy named
Charlie Diaz and in fact I run around
with Charlie's son right now but but uh
but they they had just done a robbery
and they showed up and and I was I was
trying to I was about eight I guess nine
eight eight or nine and house house
sensor are we here oh you go all out no
no I was trying to I was I'm gonna can
cut anything I was trying to get the
next-door neighbor girl to lift up or
choke and she no no she wouldn't do it
and then Charlie and Gilbert pulled up
right and they just done a robbery now
they were worried they were word black
pants black shirt you [ __ ] badass black
cop Oh God and and they were for showing
you know your counter oh yeah a bunch of
ones right so these give me a
wisely we don't them [ __ ] the ones $16
years over $16 well I got all these
wanted and I seen this girl ugly and I
peeled out three and she's okay so she
all you need is dull be a gangster and
guys that was my death my role my he
gave me a fixed size about 12 yeah and
then we just went from their eyes you
know drugs drugs alcohol you got you got
three alternatives death institutions or
insanity you know me that's yeah that's
all yeah every guy I just kept my just
kept going to jail yeah I would to do it
all so many times I thought Mexicans
were supposed to go you know number
brothers Mexicans age yeah you're
supposed to be here and that's just kind
of the way that we grew up in the
neighborhood and then it's kinda like in
jail like a pile of [ __ ] now where do
you want to be you want to be on the
bottom or on the top hmm you know so I
think my uncle he was up he was Golden
Gloves and so he was I was a sparring
partner Bank I'm gonna be wasted by the
twelve you know and no so I got really
good good at the lightweight the
waterway champion a very institution I
was in and Anna and it was but
penitentiary fights a little different
yeah kind of like it I think that's
where the MMA got it's gotta start you
know cuz every everything is legal blue
head but you know elbows just gotta know
how to do yeah you know and one night
when I come out of the joint
it was like like okay I'm either gonna
take drugs and alcohol out of my life
her or I must spend the rest of my life
in the pan mmm yeah you know took drugs
and alcohol got into a self-help group
stayed and yeah I just celebrated 50
years of being awesome love you that's
awesome I got a I got a phone call I've
been working with people since I got out
I got a phone call in 1985 I got out of
69 1985 I got a call from a kid that
said hey can you please come down here
man I got there's so much cocaine here
it's like crazy and he was trying to
stay off of cocaine yeah and an 85 I
don't remember man but 85 cocaine I
still walk in the production office and
they'd have cocaine lines on the in
Hollywood yeah [ __ ] yeah dude and most
of the stunt guys were doing it and
doing it and damn you're not I had one
cocaine run in in 1962 and one good run
and let me tell you that that'll stop
you and so we uh I went down to just
hang out with this kid yeah it's funny
that walked on set oh so he's on the
movie he's I didn't know what he was
told me gave me an address to a
warehouse
oh yeah I thought we were gonna we're
gonna sit outside when he comes out on
break smoke cigarettes drink coffee then
easily go back inside everybody's gonna
think we're gay to do cinema yeah and so
so but I walked on the movie set of a
movie called runaway train with Jon
Voight yeah a little bit about it I was
trying to be extra you know uh-huh
runaway train yeah yeah first thing I
say you want to be this movie I said
what do I gotta do he says do want to be
extra nice extra what can you act like a
convict I'm thinking San Quentin Folsom
solid dad yeah yeah I'll give it a shot
I walked on you know they give me a blue
pair of blue pants I put them on a blue
shirt I took off my shirt and I got that
big yeah yeah tattoo time yes
that tattoo you know well that was done
in the pen
yeah yeah needle is rate I'll never get
the guy goes I kid you wait does that
that's I thought what [ __ ] gang is
that he said leave your shirt off this
other dude comes across and says you're
Danny Trejo yeah he says I saw you in
the light weight and the Walter White
title up in Quintin well I thought I
fought for the the lightweight title was
the main event and and I want both and
and and uh he says Daniel you still
fight him I was a [ __ ] no you crazy up
forty years old yeah and he said he said
we need somebody to trade in one of the
actors how to box
mmm what's it pay and they were gonna
give me 50 bucks for acting like a
convict yeah yeah he says 320 a day um
hell yeah that's how bad that sounds
like a hit are 24 in the joint yeah I've
done it for another 50 bucks
yeah and I started training in Eric
Roberts oh wow how to powder box amazing
to runaway train
that's all sir Ector saw me and saw that
I I look like cuz they had they had
another dude gas to fight Eric but he
looked like I'm Tony who bombed at us
uh-huh so we don't like the that was to
clean battle do Queens yeah but yeah for
sure but Eric's Purdy yeah
I should tell I'll kiss you I met
amazing actors I met the first time I
don't know if you remember I met the
first time with Eric Oh means what so
anyway so I started training Erik and
Andrei Konchalovsky the director saw
that Erica kind of listened to me
so he said you being moved I'll never
guess it you be in movie if you fight
Erik and movie and you be my friend
well you know if you got a pigeon
background you don't like that you be my
friend
kisses be a one-sheet kisses me on the
other cheek and walks away
I tell Eddie bunker Derek look I'm gonna
train you for 320 but if I'm gonna be
kissing that old man I want more money
so me and Eric became I mean Eric came
friends and me and Andre became friends
but I met Mike we were at the Arsenio
Hall Show and Eric was there mm-hmm and
and I never forget I never sounded more
like a little [ __ ] in my life no they
would wait because they tell Eric a
Mike's here and and and Eric oh I tell
Mike I want to see him I said Eric
Mike's a heavyweight champ of the world
you don't call him like that man
no we're friends I didn't know and then
there's a knock on the door I open the
door awesome yeah he was cool he was
cool that's all Sony any Eric Roberts
party stories fighting me fight somebody
yeah was it yeah always can't really
care finally
but like he was trying to you'd be
picking hates with people let me tell
you the bad the bad thing about
Hollywood okay the bad thing about
Hollywood is you got a guy that anybody
a do one karate movie and all of a
sudden you're the karate expert
hey wait a minute you fought a stunt guy
[Laughter]
I did a film Conair yes and they had I
was a good one they had all the wannabe
bad guys yeah it's one plane right and
they had one guy his name was uh Benny
you Kiedis Benny the jet okay bye [ __ ]
yeah five-time world champion kickboxer
right I mean he kick your head off him
and Chuck Norris you have unbelievable
fights both trained by Bruce Lee okay so
so like they're all the area if you if
you if you spit on this on the set
somebody else would spit further and
then big spit contest right really
everything was a continent and every
lunch when they would start that [ __ ]
Benny Benny kids because he knew because
I grew up with older brother older
brother Marvel is bad right he's older
Ben come come on come on and he pulled
me and we'd go to the dojo
he'd say Benny wait he pulled me up
there Danny
cuz you don't play good with others I
know y'all ready you're like my brother
you're not a good sport you don't lose
you get even so so but but uh that was
just like such a fun [ __ ] movie oh man
I'm sure what give us into those stories
man it has some great actors Steve
Buscemi Nic Cage
mm-hmm yeah love Steve yeah [ __ ] they
had all the bad guys there right and
Nick gave uh it was a compliment or not
because they were all talking about how
tough they were and cases hey only guy
I'd be afraid to meet an Ali's Danny
yeah
and so people would come into the dojo
they probably do it to Mike to come into
the dojo and say hey can I borrow a
couple rounds with you yeah and and and
Betty's okay but you if I slip and sock
you don't be [ __ ] you but they just want
to be able to say yo and the first five
years of my career I played inmate
number one yeah or bad guy or in Chicano
dude or dude Mexican guy I but I didn't
I didn't know what typecast was I didn't
know what
Theriault I didn't know no that [ __ ] I
just know I was getting paid yeah you
know and every time I would go to a film
I'd work three days I make 320 a day hmm
you know so to me [ __ ] I mean 900 the
foliage and then finally the first time
I ever got uh what do you call it
interviewed by some some little girl
that just probably fresh out of
interview schools um she said Danny
don't you feel you're being stereotyped
already talking about well yeah you're
being typecast as what are you talking
about Jesus Wow well you're always
playing the me Chicano dude with tattoos
I thought about it
I lifted up my shirt I said lady I am
that's you so it's like I was gone with
what God gave me
yeah I know a whole lot of dudes that
are waiting in the gym for leading roles
right right you're not taking me yes oh
no no I would do this
[ __ ] you nah make it a lot more doubt he
I feel like you were much surfer
character I came yeah that's that was
kind of coming of age yeah that was dope
boy God the Niro Pacino they'll kill ya
yeah that was it that was the one that
was the one that actually stamped me as
an actor no doubt and the funny thing is
that me and Eddie bunker actually went
there as armed robbery consultants mmm
you know yeah yeah that's cool how to do
the robberies right yeah right now
Michael Mann he woke up to it but
Michael Mann met my uncle in Folsom when
he was doing the movie that Jericho
while oh wow who's doing the movie that
Jericho Mile and no Mexicans would come
out hmm and Michael what the [ __ ] you
know shabby and Michael Mann had to talk
to the leader of the Mexican Union and
enjoy yummy which was my uncle Gilbert
another Gilbert Tewksbury about four
four different guys that well ran that
joint so he became friends with my uncle
he paid my uncle sag scale all the time
he was oh that's it I did that so sag
scale was like 300 bucks in sure so now
uncle came came came out yeah came up
and uh and uh and so when I walked onto
the set he said Gilbert
no no I'm Danny and and I'd worked with
him before but he missed oh wow
and we talked and uh that's all ZZ so he
gave me the role of oh I forget the
dough portrayal yeah yeah uncle it gave
me one script with my name Tom or
something another one with James he's a
Danny you know what I just don't feel
right calling unity but Gilbert was
around if I called you Gilbert trailers
now so in the movie my name is Gilbert
rail Wow now that's my uncle's name
that's pretty amazing yeah yeah and he
asked me what what what happened give
our zod died Oh No
he was sad but I brought him a picture
of I gave him his picture of just the
head of the whole tip right I says just
don't let the feds see that my kid he's
just cracked up that's awesome
Mike you like heat he [ __ ] sick dude
one of my favorite movies yeah yeah that
was one of the best you know what that
thing is saved me from more traffic
tickets
[Laughter]
stop hey you did a movie yeah yeah yeah
well slow it down it's awesome well
you're in LA legend man you might
appreciate that God anything you need
let me know
we need anybody you need any closing
words from you man well I just want to
say yeah I like your work Danny and now
one of your quotes that really stick
with me is every good thing that's ever
happened in my life happened as a direct
result from helping somebody else I
really that really hits home I don't
know helping and serving people and good
things will come I love that know people
think they got to do this whole big
fundraiser you know what it's like every
one of my friends every one of my
friends they either keep socks
or thermal underwear or dog food for the
dogs in their trunk anything because you
know we've got people on the streets
that have been homeless for years yeah
their chronic homeless there
they've already adjusted to you know
they need more therapy than than a home
yeah but then connection we got people
that have lost their houses that are
homeless that are living in cars yeah
you know because so those people just
need a hand up yeah they do that's all I
mean homelessness it's a it's a really
it's brutal in LA
we've got a bad such situation here what
what in your mind could we do to remedy
that car said he's done quite a bit as
far as because he understands that
there's people like you know you have a
single mother
you know she's make trying to make ends
meet sprains her ankle
bang that's it she's done right you know
I mean cuz all of a sudden now she can't
go to work yeah and she conceived it
yeah and out there yeah that all of a
sudden she's got her kids in the car so
it's like people like that they okay
here let's move you into this yeah yeah
the people definitely need compassion
exactly no because a lot of times you
know you see these people on the street
you're like oh they're just make it bad
choices they need better choices no
people are stuck they need a couple
minutes you know you spend a couple
minutes with them you show them some
compassion you show em give him your
number
see I'm down to help you give them some
resources and just cash and give him
five minutes ten minutes instead of
looking the other way because that's I
got he said it's so funny because in the
70s seventies when Reagan closed all the
mental health yeah right clothes mafia I
used to work for Rancho Los Amigos and
Norwalk state hospital and he closed
them and says we're gonna take care of
these people on the street young in in
in halfway house but he never built the
halfway out yet so all these people so
we've had people on the streets since
then they've become family or they got
kids in school that are homeless yeah
you know so those that they need therapy
to learn how to live back in in a
structure yeah right you know and but
like I said the mom that just lost her
her job you know all she needs is help
up your help up not a handout it's not
that difficult just help up you know
give him a couple minutes because when
you're in that funk when you're in that
realm sometimes things get overwhelming
and you're trying to figure it out you
just need someone to I mean we're out
there every day just talking
strategizing giving somebody a hand up
so that they get out of the situation
that they're in
Rodell I mean that's that's awesome work
you guys man
well we appreciate you coming man
you're off to come back always I mean
it's like whatever maybe just go it's
just so hard for me to get around we've
been busy dude yeah yeah but I love it
what they say a busy man has time to do
everything
yeah no doubt how about the Rams East LA
parade right I know a lot of people that
are getting behind the ramp oh yeah
absolutely
la loves a winner man whatever you talk
we got a coach he just got out of high
school yeah yeah I know
one is 32 and he's brilliant days he
knows God he you know he just he
understands bar he understands football
yeah if you don't hear the whole thing
you didn't and it's amazing to watch to
watch it genius at work yeah it's
exciting man Mike another great one
brother we're having a good time any
time for sure man we'd love to have you
have you around man no he talked about
some of your other movies we'll talk
about yeah just or some of the fights
yeah you know what when you if you ever
watched desta dawn in the theater and
when selma hayek is pouring that wine
downer foot yeah yeah and quentin
tarantino's yeah look at the audience
every dude the audience good well we're
gonna keep this train rolling man and
thank you guys for watching let's make
another great show Thank You Danny
thank you Thank You Danny you guys are
awesome and keep doing the great work
you're doing that's cool awesome we're
out of here gone all right
[Music]